if you feel like you're built for more
if you want to grow if you want to
improve if you want to become a better
human
but you don't have people around you
that also want to
you're scared that you're going to lose
friends you're scared that you're going
to be alone as you start to go out on a
journey of self-improvement
how can people find the courage to do
that
well one thing they can do is
contemplate the consequences of not
doing it
you lose friends well
you're going to lose the friends who
don't want the best for you
those the friends you want in 10 years
i mean you lose friends well maybe you
gain new friends maybe gain better
friends
or maybe miracle of miracles your
friends
pick up their their mess too and move
forward maybe not and i'm not
i'm not naively optimistic about such
things but
you have to contemplate the price you
pay for inaction and this is something i
did with my clients all the time it's
like
well i don't want to change jobs well no
wonder
it's like you have to go put yourself
out to be interviewed
you have to send out 500 resumes
you have to be rejected 499 times
you have to polish your interview skills
you have to update your cv which means
you have to take a
real look at the inadequacies in your
preparation
um and maybe you won't find a better job
it's like no wonder you're afraid of
that okay you're in this job you hate
and it's 10 years from now
how does that look think about that
you already know you're in a little hell
you know perfectly well it's going to
get worse
which is more frightening action or
inaction
well the thing about inaction is you're
blind to it eh
so you can hide from it well that's
chapter three again do not hide things
in the fog
do not make the assumption that inaction
has no price and so then you think
i'm terrified of this but i'm even more
terrified of that
and you know people have asked me for
example
i suppose why i was willing or am
willing
to
engage in the troublesome process of
objecting when i think something isn't
going well
because i'm more afraid of the
consequences of
inappropriate silence it's not that i'm
brave
it's that i'm more terrified of the
alternative
so so i don't engage in the alternative
and
i i don't know maybe i have a knack for
that to some degree maybe it's a
consequence of clinical training but you
know i can walk into people's houses and
look around and i think okay
there's something up here and i mean
people have that ability
you know i walked into a house once and
and
the dishwasher was in the middle of the
kitchen and and it was
undone and had obviously been there for
a couple of weeks and the fridge
had food in it that shouldn't was no
longer food
and the cupboards had unopened wedding
gifts in them
like five years after the marriage i
thought there's a lot of things
in this household that are being swept
under the rug
and that was all laid out in in the
in the practical environs
it's like they hadn't negotiated who was
responsible for cleaning the fridge
they hadn't even been able to open their
wedding gifts it's like
something's rotten deeply so
and so i
i could see where that was headed
without a tremendous amount of effort
on the part of the p and it didn't work
they were divorced you know
a couple of years after that in a very
ugly manner for very ugly reasons
well i knew where that was headed you
know and
under different circumstances i would
have said
what the hell is that box doing there oh
you know it's nothing yeah no wrong
it's not nothing that's a little portal
to hell
i can see it and so could you if you
looked but you won't
and i mean that literally because people
won't look they'll walk into a room like
that
and they will not look at that thing
absolutely
and that's because if they look they'd
see
and they don't want to see and no wonder
but the consequence of blindness is
worse
it's it's worse i mean i have this
you know my family is would like some
peace
uh because i seem to be embroiled in one
thing after another and
you know they have a point
but peace is very hard to obtain
and i can't be blind to what i see in
the broader world around me not if i see
it
if i see it it's like there it is i'm
gonna say something
you talk about heroes and how they're
they're called to do the duty that only
they can
because they can not because they're
willing the person that needs to go and
slay the dragon is the person who can
not the person who wants to look well
look
look here think about it this way like
some things bug you
and other things don't i mean there's
lots of things that could bother you
that don't because you're obviously not
bothered by everything that you could be
bothered by right because there's lots
of things in the world that aren't set
right
but some of them really bug you maybe
they make you cynical and bitter you
know
oh god look at how the world is
constituted it's so awful that i can't
sustain my faith in the sight of that
it's like well you've got something to
do there
guy that's your problem why
who knows i would say the reason
is that it's your destiny calling to you
in the form of guilt over unfulfilled
obligations
you have an instinct for growth that's
not a mystical statement
it's part of being human we we don't
reach the limits of our potential
we're we're neotennic in some sense
we're continual children
biologically speaking and so we're
always
transforming and changing in some
direction
what direction well your conscience
tells you at least in part this bugs you
well it's your problem
now you may have to investigate that and
straighten it out because even your
formulation of what bugs you
is likely to be
ill-constituted but still that's
that's something calling to you
and you you avoid it at your peril and
everyone else is
peril too and it is see that's the way
that your biology manifests itself in
such a sophisticated
manner it's beyond you
it's like your better self is attempting
to manifest itself by
torturing you with a set of problems
that you need to address
and then you can refuse that but
but then all the meaning goes out of
your life if you do that
that that's not good thank you very much
for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy peace